can you count mug
[Applause]
clubs I say the future is
ours If You Can
Count
itus now look what we have before us we
have louder with Crowder right next to
Alex Jones we have Nick doollo right
next to Mr gunen gear on today's show
alone you have Brian count right next to
Gerald
a and nobody is trolling nobody and that
is a
miracle now there a lot of people out
there who want to shut this club down
but we own these
platforms with billions of plays and
millions of subscribers and many more
Millions to
come there's over half a dozen shows on
mug club with many more coming each
month millions of fans and supporters on
Facebook and Twitter
alone and there ain't no damn moderators
in the whole place can you dig
it can you dig it can you dig
it remember none of this is possible
with out you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at
louderwithcrowder.com mug club
today we'll be covering everything
tonight and I give you my word that
we'll not only be up to the minute and
as good as any of the Legacy Media
Outlets but better they all have to walk
on eggshells for fear of the tech
overlords removing them we don't have to
mug club and its viewers are linked to
together in their cause they want to
know why you give the power back to the
user and I think we all made a mistake
in 2016 gasoline prices are up 60% so
this is all the fun I get to have we're
looking forward to the debate I believe
we have a compromised
president got
electoral I'm just sorry Joe said uh may
come in hard for Republicans at first
interesting no he said he was hard no
that's what
by the way none of that checks out 2
million early votes were cast we are
gearing up for 2024 which I believe is
the most important election of our
[Music]
[Applause]
lifetime
[Music]
what I
know oh that's good I'm not just I'm not
just saying that really it's not just
lip service H it's
delicious I don't know what kind of a
tea I have no idea it's kind of luck of
the draw with a tea bag Johnny boy just
tosses it in there and you know
something hot on my vocal cords you know
so I don't sound like ethyl merman but
uh and sometimes I do sound like ethyl
merman name that movie line glad to be
with you we have a lots to get to today
that's I guess kind of become the really
big show of the we have a lot to get to
today really big show do you guys want
me to keep saying that or are you
annoyed by it you can admonish me I just
realize I always say that because I'm
always looking at the rundown that we
provide to you so uh Donald Trump Jr his
account was hacked that's not
necessarily a huge story but it's
funny not funny because it was hacked
it's funny what they said yeah Bron is
now going to use a a a uh Bron is going
to use a trans female with a with with
boobs cut off for a new commercial on
the point is you get it and then in New
York City they're going to be removing
uh the George Washington statue they're
looking to do that they're looking to
get rid of Washington monuments I don't
know if you know this uh but he freed
his slaves upon his death because
slavery was a thing back then and uh he
was actually notoriously anti-slavery he
was existing in a world that was pro
slavery so I feel like Washington
deserves a little bit more of a defense
than he actually gets and then look F35
what do you think actually happened to
the F-35 jet there are a lot of
conspiracies out there we'll be talking
about that thing you know there are
there are pieces of this thing that were
found but the government doesn't do you
any favors when they when everything is
opaque they just lean into the stories
yes so we'll we get into that and more
and uh Gerald a number two CEO how are
you I'm doing well how are you my neck
is still bothering it is I know and
yesterday everyone was telling me you
know from the chat like get traction do
this right everybody's got a solution
yeah it's a little bit better it's a
little bit better there only two ways
that you hurt your neck you guys can
comment below if you know the two ways
that you hurt your neck one of them is
Whiplash and when you hear
this you know who he is there in third
chair he's going to be at the genese
theater in uh Wan Illinois that's a
funny name that's Sunday September 24th
you can see his whole uh Tour line up
there brian.com Brian K are you sir I'm
a man Wan sounds like I sneezed is that
it doesn't sound at all like a sneez
well that's what I do say Wan like that
yeah that sounds like you're faking it
you're noing at all it's I'm a Native
American uh impressario is the word
is that what it is there's
actually a group now you seen this
advocating for Mission Control can bring
it up there's Redskins wait wait Matt
who does overlay are you partially red
skinn I am what percentage it is here on
I don't know because my grandmother
won't give me the percent that sounds
like every girl in Los Angel blond hair
blue ey well I'm
nut and Swedish yeah yes exactly more
than Liz Warren we'll put that way oh
nice it's Elizabeth Warren to you you're
hon as much as Warner Herzog is Cherokee
I was going to say is that where you get
your cheekbones as I smoked the peace
pipe howow Chow with all of my friends
and wrote my cookbook for a New York
Times bestseller I hoped that they would
not discover the fraud that existed
Within Me Spirit cooking I was in fact
unable to communicate with the
beers and then we can't get them to stop
that's a good ide no it is very good ah
all right so Brian K that's going to be
a lot and you know what hey before
anything else if you see this I know
we're on YouTube so hit the like button
but if at any point and I guarantee you
you will today you see this while you're
on
YouTube that means head on over to
rumble there's like a 5-second delay and
uh we just hit the sensor button for
YouTube and once we run out of delay uh
you know we just get suspended again
worth it yes all right so uh before we
get to any of the other stories here um
I guess this is I haven't seen this
because they wanted me to be surprised
oh yeah you'll be surprised here's a
wife coming out as gay to her husband
that's all I have written early this
year I came out as gay to my husband
insufferable uh soon to be ex and he had
the sweetest and most action and this is
what he said what did you say I said
that I was so proud of you and that was
the this thing I've seen that and that
he likes to watch and now we are going
our separate ways and we're about to put
this house on the market and that's all
she wrote be like my
ex-husband yeah be that good of a person
look Public Service Announcement uh be
exactly like the opposite of that
ex-husband just to be clear now I don't
know every action that he's taken just
so there could be some exceptions but as
I've always said the exception does not
prove the rule as a general rule
whatever that man does do the exact
opposite of him yes at least he gets
laid now and and by the way do me do me
a favor lady how about you be a good
person instead of the lying that
you are you married a man under false
pretenses and by the way when you came
to him and said I'm gay and want to
divorce he said oh thank
God that's exactly
right there you go his dating profile
with that beard did you see that beard
that goatee of his that Lucifer that
luciferian beta male look yeah I was
going to say he doesn't have a guy Fier
goatee he has a goatee that looks like
guy
Fier he's like will you leave if I do
the video for you yeah his his pronoun
done yeah his pronoun is pearshaped
yes he like he's Chanty G he likes to
watch didn't she he's obviously taking
the out didn't she get the hint when he
woke up from a coma and they said oh
that's the most he said in two days he
heard your voice and went and he went
back to sleep yeah exactly oh you want
to divorce me cuz you're gay oh you're
so brave yeah you're so
bra yes well wait she bravely takes half
hey if it's two women do they get a
100 who do they pick to take half from
yeah I don't
know there's got to be a guy somewhere
close just a Chain Gang of gold
diggers no she can look forward to
domestic abuse because lesbians beat the
crap out of each other yeah that is true
is that true true oh yeah the domestic
abuse F actually think we still have
battered lesbian. org batter
lesbians.com does start with rough
wrestling I'm getting
no it starts with a disparity and power
with lesbian couples because unlike with
gay couples where you both have the
nuclear option with lesbian couples
there usually tends to be one you it's
pretty pretty dud likee and is just the
one willing to resort to violence most
quickly so domestic abuse rampant in
lesbian households non-existent in gay
household lay off me I'm
star yeah I'll go with it muffins I
don't know what you think his husband
was surprised weren't you tipped off by
a Rocky and bbop nose ring well he was
already he was also in the background of
the of the Tik Tok thing he was kind of
in the background and he was shuffling
around waiting for his queue and she
went action and he was like this is the
most Brave thing I've ever seen in my
life he couldn't even move his mouth is
you're incredibly Brave as with her
sociopathic smile she's like get back in
get back I said okay and we're selling
the house and we're did you take a step
forward yeah she calls in her muscle
sorry lover all right prison liberal
prison you know what I think this is as
good a time as any because my neck is
and since Gerald came right out of the
shoot guys leave a comment if you like
seeing Gerald when he he came right out
of the Sho with lying which is
very rare for Gerald thought it was
descriptive yeah but for a Christian man
I have to say that was very old
testament so I actually think that today
you seem fired up you should be in this
chair and uh we'll swap it's time for a
Chinese fire drone does that mean I get
to yeah you go to jail let's just yeah
you know different perspective it's all
about it's all about
perspective all about perspective and I
get this perspective a prospectus
perspective prospectus oh oh boy
prospector which is the game lesbian
plays with her new husband wow I feel
taller I feel taller and more
Christian out the audio pleas oh my go
this audio at all oh your screens I'm
like freaking tall look at this I have
to put this up to man height
yeah my head's being cut off I have a
short fer bone I have a short fer bone
that's my fa well I mean we planned
potentially to do this but we didn't
plan to do this well you said lying
Gerald kind of happened all right fine
yeah look I I mean if you want to zoom
in on my pecs that's fine I'm not
against it zoom in zoom in on those
formerly Notre Dame pecs his knee gave
away as I've told you though I'm not a
boob guy so that makes make this next
story fun don't tell end that she's very
tired of the fact that there aren't
enough boobman out there I'm not a boob
guy I was waiting for it thank you very
much he's more of a guy guy
guys I'm gay I hate all of you hey hey
hey can I do the show please yeah go
ahead I'm just kidding go ahead all
right so um there's not a whole lot to
this story other than some hilarious
tweets our buddy Don Jr his Twitter got
hacked this morning or he's on the first
of many Benders I don't think he's
actually somebody who partakes a he's
completely sober I don't think anything
happen to him I promise but these tweets
are kind of gold so let me let me rock
through these really quickly uh someone
else tweeted somebody else someone
hacked his this is not this is not him
this is not him but it's really funny
hey I just realized hold on a second we
handed this over to Gerald on this
segment and I don't know if Gerald has
the the self-awareness to realize that
you don't actually say the n-word that
was
tweeted yeah just I just realized we you
know we took a was my okay good was my
opportunity I'm going to have to bleep
half the words in these tweets what are
you talking you're getting a few letters
that's all been waiting all day all
right so this first one and this this
one got a lot of traction quickly
obviously I'm sad to announce my father
Donald Trump has has passed away I will
be running for president in 2024 yeah
this just in the next tweet this just in
North Korea is about to get smoked I
think everybody's fine that sounds like
something he would say yeah that does I
don't know that maybe he took it back
over you know for a minute and then got
back out that sounds like something he
would say this next one though F Joe
Biden stupid a nword you can say stupid
ass NW there you go you said it I don't
need to say ninja ninja yeah ah I can't
say that because that's going to be code
word for racist stuff and later on
they're going to to come back at me and
use this episode against me oh this is
this is
probably this isn't going to go this was
a little
fiery I also effed your girl by the way
Logan Paul oh come on that was him
saying it not me obviously the hacker
right the hacker hacker yeah I don't
think there's really a whole lot more to
that story other than I really hope you
get your account back quickly because Mr
Trump Jr did you ever hear what Joe
Rogan tweeted after somebody hacked his
uh his Twitter he I didn't he said uh
did he say if you he said did you know
that bears they eat their own children
it's
crazy that that crazy the bear will eat
it the kids going wow you know what you
got
it they had trouble spelling that loud
the thing is look just people no that's
not making Joe Rogan like his nature
facts are right that's what's crazy but
just he has so many okay go ahead a
great grizzly bear does he yes he he
said uh what do you mean he does a great
Griz he does a great stop it he do a
great grizzly bear impersonation so
that's I just Little Couple facts about
this is The Joe Rogan fact uh minute all
right and then he tweeted if if he
tweeted if you guys start seeing um
random pictures of large black dicks
you'll know I got my Twitter back so
that's pretty good it's a pretty lean
joke pretty lean joke good for him maybe
it was a little leaner than that but uh
moving on I see your job is difficult
sometimes you know coring people thank
Brian I can't concentrate he just said
vascular after I said dick the more you
know he didn't say that though I think
Brian's a little distracted I can see
his eyes are going all I told him I said
by the way you're going to be in my seat
and you're going to see the chaos of my
screens so I hope you can deal with all
of that he's like Oprah if there's a
monitor of himself he has well so this
is something I
think I've never been compared to Oprah
he looks at himself on there and he's
like you want to see my impression of
Oprah every time she's on
air
mhm
right
and she looks up to the camera for maybe
like three seconds it's all about her
monitor yeah I love it can't stand yeah
all right so moving on um there's a bit
of a commercial that's come out but we
don't actually have video of this
commercial did you see this in like an
article or something like that I saw an
article yeah Daily Mail which of course
so it's Proctor and Gamble their brand
Braun right and it was in The Daily Mail
they refer to this brand as a grooming
brand I think they mean just like real
grooming not like pedophile grooming
yeah the other grooming could be both um
but they're they're in hot water for the
new ad featuring a trans dude so this oh
boy wow wow the picture there is I don't
know if that's a picture from their
actual ad I I don't know if they test
screened it but obviously this was
something that was it was covered in
Europe so we were looking for if anyone
has it you can send it in chat uh if
there's you know some kind of a leaked
version right so the the model using the
series X hybrid trimmer has uh big old
myectomy scars as you could obviously
see there and uh well they're actually
using the same technique to Market yeah
they have they have now they've been
using the same so this is now for men's
products not just men's now a lot of
it's all conglomerate right because
they've been doing this for a while and
we have the commercial that they stopped
airing but we yeah for a women's razor
here you go when it's time for a shave
use bronze Comfort Flex razor its curve
design fits the Contour of any leg pop
the blades off with the touch of a
button and be ready in 5 minutes
sensitive skin needs the sensitive Touch
of
[Music]
Brun
yeah that's I think uh
[Music]
saying um statistically speaking hey wow
hit the dump yoube make sure you hit
that button hit the YouTube dump button
for Gerald that was early onist but you
know speaking of but hold on but do hit
the like button though if you're putting
Braun to your boycott list I think
that's for abely sorry Brian Brian
speaking of what well suicide Brian is
that where you're going is it going to
be a dark moment no I was going to say
that you know Braun if Braun should
probably have a waxer or a plucker for
when that person decides that
transitioning was a bad idea and wants
to D transition what are you looking at
Brian is there a silver on your I was
looking at my fingers I was looking down
at my fingers cuz it's co the your money
maker is right there do you need do do I
need to shut off Brian's monitors there
I is that my camera right there your
camera I was I was I'm looking around
like some many pass definely staring at
the show oh right I forgot someone pass
Brian no you can't pass they pass notes
to Gerald they do pass breaking news you
can't pass them to Brian his brain
doesn't work that way no passing to
Brian oh my God yeah it says I told you
you guys it's not fair to Bri what's
that it's just a picture of a cat not
pick is from he like from Ed he like P
like P and bottle rock that oh wait this
just in guys that pick is from an ad
that pick is from an ad miscellaneous
mad over there s
him well he he wrote e instead and I was
like pick his hand it's not easy is it
and it's not easy by the way it's not
easy being I like that chair I got to
say third chair is pretty gam pretty
pretty
comfortable get to lob stuff over all
right all right so look uh we are New
York City gosh they just can't get
anything right right now um and they're
actually kind of facing one of their
biggest problems I think right now that
they're trying to solve
rats no Asians being pushed by
African-Americans under the third rail
of the subway cars you know that's high
on the list but it's not their main
problem right now their main problem
right now is apparently removing more
statues the city council is advancing a
bid to remove statues of controversial
historical figures yeah this would
include figures such as as George
Washington who knew he was controversial
Thomas Jefferson Peter Stenson and
Christopher Columbus I'm glad that guy
at least had the presence of mind to go
wait George Washington yeah except
everyone knew I know everybody knows
that everyone everyone knows it as cont
I mean if AB Lincoln is controversial to
the left George Washington and here's
the problem too A lot of people don't
know the history where that black and
white gray issues which if they're on
YouTube you'd have to go to we'll be
uploading it on YouTube I guess at some
point probably I think it's next week
there was that the black lady who was
basically a white white Suburban lady
who happened to be black right she was
and she and and I mean that because
everything was a very very wealthy
privileged Suburban experience and she
said that you know George Washington and
Thomas Jefferson were out there and they
were like she thought that they fought
for the Confederacy basically oh God and
she didn't realize how an ideals a lot
of these people were and so they apply
our current lens to you know at that
point you're talking about the 1700s I
but I I have no idea why people don't
know his especially people in power in
New York City it's like you're pandering
to an audience that doesn't want what
you're selling I don't know nobody
there's no like mass movement to get rid
of George Washington statues and they're
like hey we're going to do this and get
rid of George Washington statues don't
you guys want to protest again but the
the council committee is actually
weighing removing statues uh that depict
a person who owned enslaved persons or
directly benefited economically from
slavery or who participated in systemic
crimes against indigenous peoples or
other crimes against Gerald today and
not including the overlays he Ian there
there was no overlay for this one okay I
guess yeah there is an overlay A1
statues statues from the New York book
son of a gun they just wanted they
wanted it to look like you can't do this
without reading but I have to read the
quote Yeah we always read the quotes
what in the world is otherwise they'll
think it's your words by the way I think
the same person who wrote this actually
works for YouTube because they basically
said anything yeah anything that we deem
necessary we're going to do this for and
by the way just so you know uh if they
don't remove the statue uh they're
actually going to put an explanatory
plaque there just to make sure you know
how evil of a person that this was to
tell the story about person's misdeeds
right it's like The Scarlet Letter will
be placed on the Statue yeah this this
is called chronological snobbery that's
what it is you would have been different
back then you would have been you would
have known better yeah okay I don't
think that's you can put that plaque up
there about George Washington slavery if
you put one up uh about Rosa Park's
[Music]
laziness I need further explanation on
that I you thought it was you thought it
was Brian I don't think you do she
thought it was a civil protest and she
was just she just didn't want to get up
off her
ass Sten literally made himself more
comfortable after that comment he went
he really did he sunk into the chair a
little bit he's like yeah how about that
it's like Theo when he goes yeah she was
lazy what cut Whoa by the way look here
here's the truth and you actually said
it right so you're the one that that
brought this up and brought this to our
attention like George Washington he
freed slaves upon his death that was one
thing that you already mentioned but
also there's a there's a quote from him
about what he actually thinks about
slavery right yeah here here's a good
one so I'm actually reading there's an
overlay it does work I never mean to
possess another slave by purchase it
being among my first wishes to see some
plan adopted by which slavery in this
country may be abolished right so George
Washington not a perfect man right
absolutely not a perfect man but he had
an idea that the country at some point
would adopt a policy and a law that
would actually end the practice of
slavery right and you brought up a point
before the show that I didn't know about
he freed his slaves upon his death I
knew that I knew that but I didn't know
why because there were a lot of laws you
couldn't free your slaves why well well
think about it because you can't if
slavery is the law of the land you can't
just you can't allow people to free
slaves because they'll be they free
every person they became friends with
their slaves like all right you're
free the other thing he talked about was
not where do they go where do they go so
if they maybe next door what's the
matter with you do you do you need like
you know gentrification or something
like that move a white area and take it
over the worry was most of the country
probably didn't agree with that or he
didn't know if there would be a place
off the plantation where you walk in and
go I'm free and the other guy goes not
on this Plantation yeah you're changing
the whole a free slave you mean it a
different way than I mean it yeah
exactly yeah you want it on my property
so guess what you're mine now it's BOGO
slave season um could you see them
setting up like come visit the notot
plantation today exactly no look this is
the thing you have to take into context
and you guys can comment if you knew
this about a lot of the founding fathers
and in other words it's let's it's the
chicken or the egg only you combine it
with a lie it's the hey hold on a second
we had this uh we had this declaration
of independence we had this Constitution
that all men created equal but not with
black people well no actually if you
look at the framers they were putting
that in there saying all men created
equal because they were they were that
was the spark they were deliberately
putting that in there so that they could
ensure that slavery would eventually be
a now not everybody but certainly people
like George Washington certainly people
if you look at folks like Jefferson or
if you look at people like Adams and by
the way just to be clear you can find
racist quotes from Abraham Lincoln
that's absolutely true right this is the
guy who signed the Emancipation
Proclamation he also by your current
standards probably was a little bit
ignorant you probably find some quotes
from George Washington saying we have to
do away with slavery and probably some
negative stereotypes too you know where
he's like I don't know he says like you
know they smell like chicken or
something like that you know he'll
probably say something like you're like
that's racist you're like yeah he also
wanted to free the slaves during an era
where that was the trade that was how
the world existed imagine you are trying
to up and whatever it is depending where
you are a fifth a quarter of the economy
right and you know that not everyone is
going to be on board with and you just
left the country where of course they
engaged in slavery and they were
purchasing slaves from an entire
continent that still practices slavery
yeah no it's it's one of those things
it's impossible to go back and put
yourself in that position and actually
see the complexity of actually doing it
because you have to do it at the right
time it wouldn't have worked if he had
tried to do it earlier and by the way
when George I'm sorry when Abraham
Lincoln did it it cost him half the
country yeah right so the price was
still high in the bloodiest war that
we've ever fought was fought to make
sure that among other things took place
and by the way New York if you're going
to do something and focus on stuff like
this regarding George Washington how
about you do this how about you teach
people that he is one of the only people
in history to come to power and then
give it away yeah right what was there
quote by King George basically said he
said I didn't fight this war to become
George II exactly because he said he
said you know somebody said you should
you should be the king they wanted it to
there was they wanted to make him King
he didn't even want to do this he wanted
to just live a life and kind of retire
and be out of this like he had he'
gotten you know a lot of Bones by
fighting the French and he enjoyed that
and then he had to fight with them side
by side so that must have been an
awkward first meeting like hi hey by the
way what how about we do it with JFK
yeah I mean not only Bill Clint but JFK
a lot of you don't know this you know
why Sammy Davis Jr was a republican for
the rest of his life because JFK
uninvited him Sammy Davis Jr because he
was married to a white woman I don't
know if it was a White House Press
correspondence dinner if it was
inauguration JFK uninvited him and Nixon
said you know I like the way that fellow
sings I like Mr Bojangles and he brought
him in and so he said so I'm voting
Republican for the rest of my life
B just so you know JFK and by the way I
don't think JFK was a racist I don't
think JFK hated black people I think
that different eras people hold some
different views and
[Music]
everyone's
that he may be the greatest man who's
ever lived something like that like
there's no way you can walk away from
that kind of power when they want to
give it to you not that you are taking
it it's not just that too I think that
you know Thomas Jefferson was one of the
people that solved the political problem
uh you know we have created the freest
Nation on the planet and the Very
language and the arguments and the
infrastructure that these people use to
say we've got to tear the statue down or
exercise their free speech or just the
fact that we've got to be a more equal
society that just didn't come out come
about through through thin air those
ideas had to be thought through and put
down on paper thank you James Madison
thank you Tomas Jefferson John Jay and
the list goes on and George Washington
was the Exemplar of that that's what he
fought for yeah exactly and it created
so it's it's ridiculous you're taking
credit for something you didn't do any
work for yeah and and you're just
erasing a human being because of the
fact that slavery was the order of the
day worldwide and they didn't do enough
in your mind to fight against that even
though obviously he was well yeah and
here's the thing to it's King it's King
of the Hill they're always going for
King of the Hill let's be honest the
United States of the King of the Hill
hey let me ask you this because you say
oh we took the Native Americans land
even though in some cases for example
like Manhattan they didn't have the
general we traed for it we tra we traded
like 30 gilders which is equival 10,000
tons Timber 14 and no there was a
receipt you know that I think it was the
canari came back after they left and
they said hey we like what you've done
with the place we're going to come back
now so the point is they didn't
understand the concept some of these
tribes of personal property let me ask
you this if the United States doesn't
come to be you think the Cherokee are
freeing the slaves you think they're the
Catalyst for slavery ending across
Western Civilization people say oh they
ended in England not in the British
Empire by the way that's that's a nice
little convenience still had indentured
servants still exist by the way more
slaves than ever on earth right now 42
million but if the United States didn't
come over here and by the didn't commit
genocide there are more people like Matt
there for crying out loud with
116th iroy whatever it is than ever
before because the policy was a matter
to you know to assimilate to intermar if
the United States if George Washington
right if this doesn't happen we don't
have the revolution the pilgrims don't
come on no Mayflower no Santa no Santa
Maria n none of that stuff okay do you
really think that someone else would
have been the Catalyst for really you
would have had England at that point the
greatest superpower and over here you
would had tribal Warfare never ending
yeah how does slavery end across the
globe comment below you tell me your
theory we can do it like a choose your
own path book for anyway it was
it was all the European diseases we
should have vaccinated them first that's
true if we had only had the vaccine
horses morons I don't mean all Native
Americans whenever you see them with a
bow arrow on a horse that's not until
white guys showed up from Spain yeah
they hadn't domesticated horses they
should like hey how what's up dander
does someone have a zertek
all right New York you got bigger
problems to focus on please that you
know we're going to keep track of this
story and if they end up actually taking
down statues of George Washington or
placing plaqu they are going to be made
fun of the world over because people
whether you like America or not people
probably think of George Washington
globally in a very positive light right
so you're going to have a really tough
case to make on this one all right
speaking of tough cases
military you can do us a favor
government you can do us all a favor you
would end the conspiracy theories
tomorrow if you just wouldn't lay it up
for us and maybe you're trying to do
that maybe that's the entire point it's
like some 8D chess game where it's like
oh if they talk about this plane being
you know hijacked essentially and flown
to Cuba because of his software then
they won't be talking about other things
but Tuesday afternoon Blink from 182
found a UFO what sorry Tom from Blink
182 I didn't know blink was part of the
from 182 that's he was a temporary
drummer blink ah yeah well little Harald
old on Tuesday debris from the missing
F35 was finally but stealth plane was
finally found in South Carolina oh
breaking tonight A search team just
discovering a debris field 2 hours
Northeast of Joint Base Charleston It is
believed to be the wreckage of an F35
fighter jet that disappeared on Sunday
the $100 million stealth jet crashed
after the pilot safely ejected over
Charleston South Carolina $100 million
That Couldn't bother with an air tag I
mean $100 million and they couldn't have
crumple zones yeah well that that's
that's that I understand your point here
but we do actually have an exclusive
image of the pilot ejecting it tells the
story oh that makes sense they only
found her stretchy maternity
suit well look just so you know the
military does they have designations for
when they screw up and this is a class A
mishap which is silly called the ailia
airart protocol pretty much it's like
it's a Class A mishap I just want you
guys to know that's not a bad Alex Jones
oh well I wasn't even trying I just was
going for you know a general of some
sorts tented so talented the funny part
here is they keep talking about this
number this $2 and5 million doar plus in
Damages qualifies as a class yeah you're
97.5 million dollar away from the actual
number of Damages thank you very much
media for covering the most important
point the really the class A mishap
thing is because the plane was destroyed
you morons hey uh Chad think they know
what happened to it hold on wait wait
a come on guys you can't take everything
you see folks we have to be peaceful the
F35 is mine take the plane take the
plane I got I got tips he's holding it
with one arm yeah it's pretty strong
dude and I know that's not the qinon
shaman it's the JP Sears understudy it's
not plane has vertical takeoff
capabilities it'd be fine to get out of
the White House in the capital grounds
uh the pilots actually and this is kind
of funny to me because it reminds me of
the new top gun Maverick yeah like who
just pilot just parachutes into
somebody's
backyard whoops and this quote to me
gets a little bit crazy and look we're
just we're just kind of telling you kind
of what happened I understand you've
seen this in the media but we're going
to go into some some of the conspiracy
theories about what actually happened
just to be able to dispel some of them
for you that are kind of crazy laugh at
some of them and then kind of scratch
our head and go wait a minute is this
one of those moments where we're going
to look back and go Alex Jones was right
again on one of these so there there are
a couple of these that makes sense but
here's the Pilot's
quote he's unsure of where his plane
crashed he just lost it in the weather
well I know that I know that happens to
me when it drizzles well yeah he's he's
a fighter pilot yeah with one of the
most advanced pieces of Technology on
the planet that we'll get to later by
the way when those things crash
typically countries Scurry about to try
to find them before the owners do this
guy ejected one mile north of I believe
the Charlotte Airport a main airport not
where he took off not the not the field
where he took off I don't think uh but a
major commercial airport and then by the
way he
actually let the plane fly for 60
additional miles he's uh Mr he's Mr
can't fly in
[Music]
Iceman okay I don't know what to do with
that Shame Shame AB can we admonish him
don't do a split screen of me and him
just him that's okay you canish me I I
won't even be in the chair because oh
come
on
stinker did you urinate yourself no he
looks good
wet he look rain I just don't fly good I
didn't think you got that much on you
but look the reason that this all
started kind of coming back up was
obviously you know they wanted to find
the plane did you know the government
was like hey anybody seen a plane yeah
they literally reached out to the public
to see if they could help them find the
plane but apparently a debris field of
sorts has surfaced online and this is
causing a lot of speculation on what the
government is actually doing not really
telling the whole truth watch this clip
and see if you can see what is not
there bonfire yeah was that a burn pit
or something the no plane the no plane
oh boy that's a damn good St it's like a
UFO photo where you just can't make out
anything why why is there a rapist
vanin just rolling up the experts are
here hear the sound of an ice cream
truck
this is like X Files you know they roll
up and cordon off an area and there's
not really a plane there that you can
see now look I get it I get it this is a
really curious kind of accident and
given that this is not really clear we
thought it would be time for us to look
into what really is going on and that
brings us to the truth according to
Gerald
you always just scratch stuff out and
put my name in there's no original work
you're a businessman you're not stop
whining all right so we're going to go
through the the theories if you can give
me maybe like a ding here or something
like that well let's also by the way
comment below what you think it is and
we'll we'll probably take some more of
your Chats on mug club and consider
signing up lc.com mugclub you you guys
you can sign up there and of course you
have Brian Ken show every week now the
Brian oh this this chair now I hurt my
rib your chair I was laughing earlier
spine your spine is suppos mine it's
notable not a not a suppo leopard so
there are a lot of here's the crazy
thing is people are Waring with each
other where they really have dug in
their heels that they're convinced they
know what's happening and people are
going for the craziest possible theories
but the the worst part about this is
that some of them seem like possible and
others don't so here's the first one
we'll start off with one that doesn't
the the jet was shot down by local
militia using Small Arms weapons if you
can down a $100 million airplane with
small arms I want my money back exactly
I thought they had some kind of armor I
get it you think that it was shot down
by some Farmer in the field with a
shotgun got it well this this might have
been started by liberals leftist because
they may actually think you can take
down an F35 with an AR15 you know what
it is an assault weapon yeah like it was
that Lone Survivor with kefir souland
like how did he make that this actually
happened maybe someone can find this
clip in episode they go how did he make
that shot from 600 yards away they go we
found out sir he had an
AR-15 that doesn't explain why he was
able to like a 600 yard shot exactly
it's like wanted where he's curving the
bullet this makes zero sense he shut
down a jet Brian that's like uh pull up
the Twitter post on that again P pull it
up I want to see how much interaction
this thing has gotten do we n don't have
that do do me a favor guys let me know
how many people are buying into this one
because we need to be able to mark these
people you know and avoid them you know
what I think it could have been a wild
goose well so it's he's definitely no
Sully did he fly yeah did he fly into a
a bunch of GE he's like I don't I don't
have a river to land bird strike yeah
how not out there that's that's my
theory hey Brian you know why I don't
think that's the theory why because
you're because the plane flew for 60
more miles yeah well that's cuz it goes
60 miles per second oops I do or maybe I
just gave up a secret I gave up a secret
unless the geese like like storks they
had like little bandages and They
Carried the plane another
60 they like the FL like The Flintstones
they're like like they're like
pterodactyls carrying they like carrying
an F35 like this job
sucks and they took it in as one of
their own there's nowhere to grab a jet
obviously Somalian you don't know much
about Stealth Fighters and then it
dawned on me that Brian Kalen took
things far too
literally a state of repressed childhood
from which he could never recover due to
his attack from the beers dear diary be
more
metaphorical
de Steven found out my flaw on air it's
a rough couple of weeks for J he used
his go-to defense mechanism a mimic
miming as though he had a diary or the
ability to write
words read more fiction this illiterate
half
Italian researchers came back and said
it was only 445 views one retweet oh
who's the one idiot
who was it us no Don Junior's hack
account Don Junior's hack account is
like I found the
jet all right so here's another one uh
when they're not busy creating fires on
Hawaiian Islands directed energy weapons
took down this jet okay you
[Music]
know well what what happened who said
that well no he has a good point I mean
there is there is Jewish NASA with the
space well that's what they say Jewish
laser I thought we were talking about
directed energy no you're right you're
right you're right that's right I didn't
know I didn't I didn't make the
connection that you immedately made I
just thought it was anti-semitic it's
not anti- Ran's actually he's he's being
metaphorical because Jewish space lasers
it's actually code for
banks look man stop quoting marjerie
Taylor green I mean yeah she's right
about a lot of stuff but still not
everything all right I so but I don't
understand this one as well guys because
as I will repeat the plane flew on for
60 additional miles so maybe it's the
worst directed energy weapon ever or we
have the most trigger happy pilot ever
to get out of the plane ah energy weapon
bye yeah and doesn't actually get shot
down so that one's probably not going to
be true too but let's get to one that is
this one seemed to be making the rounds
quite a bit more and we'll see what kind
of activity the the tweets had here or I
just can't not say tweets the posts on X
like it just doesn't sound the same that
the jet was actually hacked by the
Chinese and it to Cuba of all places has
a lot more 1.6 million views because
it's Andrew Tate right okay so that
makes sense uh I I bring that back up
really quickly I want to read the one
right up there so if you're concerned or
upset about the US losing 150 million
it's aund million jet let's not inflate
it uh don't forget about okay whatever
who cares about the rest of it right but
people are talking about it being hacked
um look I know these are some theories
and we'll get back to the hacking thing
in just one second because there are
some problems with this jet I think it
runs on be clear I don't think Andrew
Tate said it was hacked by the Chinese
and diverted he said it was hacked that
it made sense that makes sense to me
like thats immediately can't control the
plane it flies on an autopilot for 60
more miles like okay maybe there was
something sensible Theory yeah it is
it's much more sensible but look we
actually have an it's real this is a
real news report I know what you're
going to think that it's not real but
it's 100% real this is a witness who
puts all the speculation to rest uh in
the bathroom taking a shave and I heard
a a
screeching s between a screech and a
whistle that's 100% real Randolph look
he's got a he's got the best dentist on
the place he does this is the best teeth
I've ever seen in my
life as a guy with yellow teeth that is
I'm jealous where does he buy the rest
of his outfit The Roots commemoration
store I that guy I was in the bathroom
taking a brush of my teeth take a shave
that's what it was shave yeah the way
he's dressed the way he's talking he's
sitting there like it's like it's like
let me see how many how many stereotypes
kind fit in here it'sit the rumble
but good God y'all you I'm going make it
sound like a goost screaming people lie
to goats go viral I'm gonna go viral do
the
go I feel good and like sir that's not
hell don't about this boy make sure see
that one that a good go where's autotune
the news when you need
it you've got some more material you
guys still around can we watch it one
more time the greatest has happened
yesterday it is the greatest interview
of all time incredible uh in the
bathroom taking a shave and I heard a a
screeching s between a screech and a
whistle very close to the goat
yeah sounds like this is going to live
forever he didn't realize that he was
going to be famous I love how he was
also he was taking a shave taking a
shave yeah he wasn't shaving he was
taking a shave taking a shave Tak all
right that's a sound I made after my
first sexual
experience what sorry is that was that
on air when you first saw a naked woman
uh inside voice yeah that's right that's
right I can use this guy for anything
her robe dropped and I
screamed I've never seen never seen a
dick I can't even go that high with the
pitch like he did pretty good he was
unbelievable that's it's incredible good
job so there are some major problems
with this jet like it's F35 it's very
technically Advanced it's it's you know
stealthy but obviously has some problems
that uh make Pilots eject but in 2018
there was a report that indicated that
53 of the I'm sorry uh the F35 had 13 uh
category 1 deficiencies that made flying
uh dangerous seems like operation number
one is to try and make flying as safe as
possible because the enemy is going to
try to make it dangerous for you so you
probably should have that one figured
out I don't know if like the wing
randomly rips off this by the way does
lend Credence to yes I I hate but the
theory that it could have been hacked
well the next one even it butresses that
even more here's the problem it's
filling in the blank saying the Chinese
hacked it and sent it to that's what
there can be something that's true and
you can have a question that's valid the
problem is when you start filling in all
the blanks as though you know and you
pedal that as though that is fact but I
mean if you were to get into a plane and
they said listen uh good news is it's
$100 million and it's an amazing piece
of Machinery the bad news is there are
13 things wrong with the aircraft that
make it that make it difficult to um um
um was it fly yeah and you go are they
big things well they're category one
send it to
Spirit one of the things is that it
loses thrust on a hot day if in landing
which you know if you're doing the
vertical kind of Landing thing and at
the wrong point because it's a hot day
you lose it that's a problem also the
battery uh when it's cold can uh uh stop
working and planes I don't know if
you've known planes they fly high you
it's typically colder up there I've
never had a problem with throat yeah
absolutely
so Brian what a there it is that's the
sound I make so in 2019 to give this
hacking thing a little bit more Credence
the defense Watchdog noted that there
was susceptibility to hacking so here's
here's this the government
accountability office released a report
in October of 2018 showing that nearly
every software enabled weapon system
tested between 2012 and 2017 can be
hacked Often by simple means like
looking up default passwords online for
commercially available software numerous
parts of the F3 program uh use this kind
of software Alis I don't know what that
is runs on Windows for example AIS runs
on windows so look I was taking a shave
taking a shave and I said to myself the
last time I thought F35 run on Windows
98 and the d d had a pass
password to plane password
would
plane 98 password to plane with plane
you were so
dumb you turn the you turn the plane on
you start me up
that almost never sto in this case it
did so but look people still love this
play just really quickly this this
program is going to cost $1.7 trillion
the F35 program it's the largest it is a
lot of nuts it's the largest program
ever at the Pentagon and it was
developed by Lockheed Martin by the way
2022 Lockheed Martin's profit $66
billion I believe one of our researchers
he can he can throw this into you uh uh
Matt I had a nickname miscellaneous Matt
there we go uh miscellaneous Matt can
have it and we we'll come up we have
three mats now we have previously fired
mat cyber mat oh is that cyber I called
him cyber I don't know makes sense to me
1.7 trillion that's get caught up in the
tril ,700 billion do that's a lot that's
1,700 billion he's a math not Asian but
I mean what you're not Asian well maybe
you got a little bit for a plane that
runs on Windows they they were telling
us it made like a million dollar like
loed Martin makes like a million
7 million an hour in profit 7 million an
hour in profit not in
Revenue we're in the wrong you want to
go into the defense business seems like
the place to be yeah and you know what
the good news is I don't know anything
about it so I can make a plane make
numchucks well we can make this one fly
for 60 miles before crashing I feel like
you hit the ejection button a little
prematurely over a populated area you're
lucky the plane did make it 60 miles
away before it crashed but look there's
16 other countries that want to purchase
these things or I'm sorry that have
purchased them among them Poland Germany
South Korea and Singapore so we're
arming people that hopefully will stay
on our side I don't think we should ever
arm Germany ever I think that's a bad
idea yeah they're the one country they
get Restless every 40 years yeah exactly
I wouldn't call like they're allies so
to speak but we can't really trust them
no I don't like it's not that I don't
trust them I don't like them unless we
can hack all their planes and fly them
to Cuba that's true then that's fine
with the pilots but then that' just be
vacation for them that's Germany's also
mostly Syrian and Turkish that's true
but look countries like China we're not
selling them to China I know what you're
thinking right now we're also not giving
them to Iran we're not abandoning them
in Afghanistan right like some of the
stuff that we've done this is really
good stuff was it was it was it 8
billion dollars worth of equipment we
abandoned in Afghanistan something like
that well yeah but it's really hard to
carry home pallets of cash those are the
things that you tend and opium they
literally left pallets of cash along
with all of the military equipment there
it's like prioritize the cash as well
just watch The Italian Job stuff it in
some duffel bags and you hear the sirens
plane I'll go get the pallets of cash
for you but China actually so the an F35
actually went down and China was dying
to get their hands on it tonight one of
the most sophisticated pieces of
military technology on the planet now at
the bottom of the South China Sea and up
for GRS the race is on appropriate kind
of recovery gear the the Chinese have it
the US Navy has it both those countries
are going to want to get a hold of this
record all right look so tell me what do
you think is the F35 a Sav Savvy
National Security investment that
ensures that we will have US Air
superiority and whatever fight that we
end up with uh in the future because of
either a stupid Administration or some
idiot dictator that tries to take us to
war or is it a trillion dollar boond
doggle suckling at the tax period TI but
here's the thing either way bu lock heat
stock yes that is a good lesson Lock
Stock that is definitely what you're
going to name absolutely buy some locked
stock and uh yeah buy buy uh don't but
by the way down I'm pretty I'm bullish
[Music]
I'm bearish on the the new technology
regarding the Air transport of pallets
oach yes we could start a company called
paleto Cash pal they're not we'll just
transport mostly flying to Iran with
this regime and then look it up for
other people and maybe just create those
if it's a $100 million just I mean you
could make them float they could double
as a boat make them more amphibian like
there I said it see I come with ideas
guys I should be there I come up with
ideas you're not he's an idea thank you
that's what I was thinking I look I
think your diary call lock heed
Martin water water wings try to get in
on the ground floor of Lockheed Martin
only if you have a DeLorean sorry guys
it's not going to happen so look our
Friday show this week is actually going
to be some behind the scenes of make
kind of the making of this show and some
of the skits and some of the opens and
in the stuff that you guys love that we
get to do where people get painted gold
which is a lot of fun so make sure you
check that out on Mud Club only and
that's only going to be available for
mug club but uh here's a little bit of a
taste of what you can
[Music]
expect right about this in the new
yor whiskey kind of balances it out I'm
looking at Tim right now and seeing how
good he looks in that
it's so stupid you want to keep it on
you and I can go do something later I
tell you to come to the
gym you want to I a't talking about
[Music]
the in your head you know they're all
cut final touches all yeah uh get the
get the chest here a little bit yeah
yeah we clean it up watch the nipple
remember like last time I could do an
arrow oh that'd be fun okay let's do an
arrow watch the nipple I said go to
manscaped.com and get 20% off plus free
shipping with the promo code Crowder 20
I'm so horny
okay no one told me they were keeping
that oh well of course come on it's a
nice razor no it honestly I got to tell
you it honestly is the uh the manscape r
this is the big thing that not enough
people talk about this light makes all
of the difference you see that it kind
of it's very flattering when you cuz it
rakes see it rakes across your look
spooky stories don't actually
accidentally shave spooky stories of a
hairless Mouse um it really does work
well like we've used them for a while
then they became a sponsor to the show
that light shows you the difference
between a wart and a mole hey Brian do
you know where that lights really useful
yeah down downstairs I didn't say that I
thought that was the implication come on
guys you're better than I call that I
call that my naughty place that's why I
keep it in the dark manscaped.com and
you use the promo C right Crow 20 you
get 20% off free shipping by the and
free shipping by the way I will say
their their uh their trimmer for their
beard is is actually like legitim it has
a little dial so you don't have a bunch
of different guards y oh that's so and
then the balls are sponsor to the show
for those of you who don't just need to
shave your balls nose hair the weed
whacker I need to start doing that kind
need it every once in a while I'm losing
hair here gaining hair in other places
it's it's kind of a weird bad tradeoff
thing it's it's cruel but also thank you
very much for the laugh track helpy
helperton I actually I actually used it
on my neck which which is why my neck
looks like you could sleep on it ah all
right Tim so before we went to this uh
we were talking about the story of the
F35 you said you had a a somebody said
they knew what it was like what what the
theory was do you still have that that
image did did you show me anage gone
yeah I showed an image oh I I'm sorry I
totally forgot what it was oh no it was
the guy holding the plane I thought
there was something else never mind all
right no my bad all right so we're gonna
start a story and then finish it uh uh
in mug Club so you'll get to hear a
little bit of what we're setting up here
and then you know you got to because
well abely you got get one of one of
these guys be able to see it it's the
secret pass it's the golden ticket if
you will um over the weekend the
Ukrainian Defense
Forces trans spokesperson this is the
one of the most strange stories by the
way the whole story on this is not just
that this person exists because we've
already addressed this person in August
but they actually went on a rant about
Russian
propagandists next week the teeth of the
Russian Devils will Nash harder and
their rabid mouths will foam in uncol
callely trying see a f of propaganda I
was going to say like you know how hard
it is to get a good wig in a war zone is
only the first Russia's war criminal
propagandists will all be hunted down
and Justice will be served as we in
Ukraine are LED on this Mission by faith
in God Liberty and complete Liberation
and it was apparent the only effort she
put into looking like a woman was
visiting Party City and asking
[Music]
for Dum button uh this is this is the
laziest part about being
trans imagine in Ukraine if you own a
wig shop business ain't a boom right now
well I mean people still need wigs they
when they're fighting battles and not
trying to you know die at least I mean
because there are a lot of layers to
this parts that are true that some some
parts that aren't true but we can all
agree it's a good thing that Draco Maloy
has found some new work so that's
nice I Wan's not going to help you buddy
I don't think it's gonna work and by the
way people they can comment if they want
us to do a deep dive onto this this uh
Disturbed individual mhm um because this
person does exist but some of the
stories around this person aren't really
true it's getting crazier as we dive
into this right so this person's cringey
and the voice and the way that they are
it seems like they're doing propaganda
right so this is an American citizen is
what we think based on what they've
claimed and there's some people that
have thought maybe they found out who
this is but trust me this story is only
going to get more crazy as we go but
look again if you uh are not on mug Club
you don't get to see that part of it
right now I'm really sorry but this is
really interesting so look if you want
us to do a deep dive maybe we'll do a
deep dive one of the other shows like
you said but uh this is the part I don't
you know I don't normally get to do
stuff like this well I know but people
need to know you know on Muk not only
you get Bri the Brian C show for all but
you also you're going to get the Hodge
twin show you get us every day 45
minutes you get Alex Jones on Friday Mr
guns and gearar uh and of course the
undercover um yeah the undercover
investigative unit by the way they the
ones who did a lot of work the reason
that that PornHub exclusive got out and
there's going to be likely legislative
action taken that's entirely because of
you at mug Club you know what a lot of
the nonprofit investigative journalism
outfits out there can't do they can't go
after companies like PornHub no they're
not allowed to do that so it really is
all because of you and uh and and that's
M Club you know today was the first that
was the first sponsor spot we've done in
a long time it is the first it's fun
though to do it you never know if
they're going to fire us well that's
true they do give us creative license
and that's your fault because you did it
but I don't normally get to say
this piss off
YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
what